What are some of the natural treatments that can help bite her to
positive breast cancer if one is not going to go and do her septum therapy?
Well, everything that we have you on, we test you on for
your cancer, is what we're doing. So
there, you know, there isn't just like any cancer. I mean, you could say the same thing. What's the
best thing for, you know, lymphoma, or what's the best thing for multiple myeloma? Well, it's very
it's rare that there is like a specific nutrient that is going to help everybody with this specific
cancer. It's everybody's different. So that's what we do the cheek swab testing and that's where we,
you know, we make our recommendations based on that. So I would say stick to your protocol
and you know, if it's metal, I don't know who has this question, but if it's went a long time,
since we did a cheek swab test and if your cancer is currently not stable, then I would say to
recheck that again.